[Music]
since then
in religion the determination of the
consciousness proper of spirit does not
have the form of free otherness
spirit's existence is distinct from its
self-consciousness
and its reality proper falls outside of
religion
there is indeed one spirit of both but
its consciousness does not embrace both
together
and religion appears as a part of
existence of conduct
and activity whose other part is the
life
lived in its real world as we now know
that spirit in its own world and spirit
conscious of itself as spirit
or spirit and religion are the same the
perfection of religion consists in the
two becoming identical
with each other not only that religion
concerns itself with spirit's reality
but conversely that spirit as
self-conscious spirit
becomes actual to itself an object of
its consciousness
so far as spirit in religion pictures
itself to itself
it is indeed consciousness and the
reality enclosed within religion
is the shape and the guise of its
picture thinking
but in this picture thinking reality
does not receive its perfect due
that is to be not merely a guise
but an independent free existence
and conversely because it lacks
perfection within itself it is
a specific shape which does not attain
to what it ought to show forth
that is spirit that is conscious of
itself
if its shape is to express spirit itself
it must be nothing
else than spirit and spirit must appear
to itself or
be in actuality what it is in its
essence
only by so doing would that also be
obtained which may seem to be the demand
for the opposite
that is that the object of its
consciousness have at the same time the
form of free actuality
but only spirit that is object to itself
as absolute spirit is conscious of
itself
as a free actuality to the extent that
it
is and remains conscious of itself
therein
paragraph 678 is the first
long paragraph now in this introductory
portion to this religion section of the
work
and i think it can be a bit confusing
upon a first or even second 10th
25th read unless you keep in mind
one main thing here which is that in
using the term
religion hegel is not naming
exactly the same thing in every instance
of the term so in classical
you know linguistics or study of
language we could say that this is not
a universal term where it designates
exactly the same thing each time
but it's more an equivocal or analogical
term and part of you know what this this
uh
you could say the key to this is that
that term the perfection
of religion when religion
is brought to its fulfillment now it's
not perfection in the sense of like
being immaculate or nothing is wrong
with it
rather this the the german word for this
is very similar to like you know
the greek term uh that gets used in
philosophy that often gets translated as
perfection
meaning to be brought to the end of its
development or the end of its
its process so that's something to keep
in mind he is thinking about that
here but he's also thinking about the
uses of religion
in previous parts of the phenomenology
as we've seen in just the paragraphs
before this and he's talking about
religion
as you know determinate shapes
of consciousness so there's there's a
you know a tension here between these
different uses of it
the other part that i think that can be
a little bit confusing for
people not because of the use of the
terminology but because of the
use of a term that in some respects
seems kind of out of place here
but we'll talk about is this over and
over again recurrence to
free and talking about that is something
that hasn't been yet
incorporated hegel talks about free
otherness free existence
free actuality so what's going on with
that well let's take a look at the
section
itself so this first first uh sentence
is a little bit tricky since then in
religion
the determination of the consciousness
proper of spirit does not have the form
of
free otherness spirit's existence
is distinct from its self-consciousness
and its reality
proper falls outside of religion so it's
it's
very kite falls out or actually falls
outside of
religion now is this falling outside of
religion
in totality or falling outside of
religion in a certain way
it's really the latter as the next
sentence reveals there is indeed one
spirit of both
but as its consciousness does not
embrace both together
and religion appears as a part of
existence
right so this is religion in one sense
it's not religion as brought to its
fruition
it's not religion as we're going to talk
about it necessarily
in this section as things are developing
this is religion as as we encountered it
like when people
say oh i don't like institutional
religion this is the sort of thing they
have in mind
right i grew up as a cradle catholic or
cradle this or cradle that and i
you know just mumbled my way through the
rituals okay that's this sort of thing
over here
that's not what hegel is talking about
in this
religion section as the essence and
ultimately actuality of of religion
so coming back to that first sentence
in religion the determination of the
consciousness proper spirit in religion
in this section
at the start it does not have the form
of free otherness
spirit's existence is distinct from its
self-consciousness so we've got spirits
existence how it is in in the world
right and then we have its
self-consciousness not just
consciousness but it's
self-consciousness how it understands
what
what it is to be spirit at this point
right
so we can line these things up
with religion as a part of existence
which we'll come back to in a moment and
then spirit in
religion so let's look at both sides um
here we go religion appears as a part of
existence
conduct and activity whose
other part is the life lived in in its
real world
now its other part is not this over here
spirit self-consciousness its other part
is the other part
on this side of spirit's existence
religion is
conduct and activity you know busying
yourself in doing things tune
conduct is probably not a good term to
use here
doing is is a better term because
usually we use
handle we translate that as conduct but
to an
okay in the broad sense if it's not just
you know taught
single action but it's acting okay
that's not bad
and the the other side of that
is still on this side of existence right
how things are in the world and and you
can think about people who
we've got this proverb you know about
people who go to church on sunday and
that's very you know
much where their center is and then the
other six days of the week
they just go back to doing whatever they
they do right
there's the combine kind of
compartmentalization going on there
then he talks a little bit later in this
this section he says
as we now know that spirit in its own
world
and spirit conscious of itself
or spirit in religion so spirit
conscious of itself
as spirit spirit in religion he says
these are the same
so the the spirit in its own world is
over here
right the spirit conscious of itself is
what religion
is supposed to be and isn't quite yet
in in this this development uh as we're
you know
going on as the phenomenologist but it's
it's
hinted at there it's it's we see the
outlines of it he says these are the
same
they're the same because they're one
spirit they will be the same when
religion is brought to
its fruition or fulfillment so he says
here we go the perfection of religion
consists in the two
becoming identical with each other
so they're not identical right now they
have to become identical with each other
that's what the religion section is
about tracing that that
progress out and he goes on and he says
not only that religion concerns itself
with spirits reality
so like you know religion would talk
about everything in human life right
you're familiar with religion as world
view right
but that through this spirit would
in a way that goes beyond the previous
developments it would become
conscious of itself like he says it
becomes
actual to accept to itself and object of
its consciousness
now how does this take place this is
where he introduces this discussion of
picture thinking
that we have talked about at various
points earlier in the phenomenology
picture thinking is the way that miller
likes to translate this
other commentators and translators very
often talk about representation
and in you know the for example in the
english translation
of hegel's lectures on the philosophy of
religion you'll often see representation
for stellen right that is the term
that's being used there another term
that that uh
miller is translating as guys clyde
literally clothing you know when i put
on
my jacket tie
dress shirt i'm in a certain you know
costume you could say i'm in a certain
guise
if i'm just wearing you know a tattered
t-shirt and
i suppose i could have accessories like
you know drinking a beer or something
like that
that's a different guys so that's that's
going to be
important here how does religion frame
itself to itself how does religion
represent itself to itself
how does how do we as human beings
represent religion
in what we're doing with it so he goes
on and he says
so far as spirit and religion pictures
itself to itself it's consciousness
the reality enclosed within religion is
the shape
gestalt we're going to talk about that
in a moment and the guys
clyda of its picture thinking
now there's a problem with this hegel
points out in this picture thinking
reality does not receive its perfect do
and here again we see the freedom being
brought up what is the
perfect do to be not merely a guise
you know something that we see that we
can talk about and refer to
it it's not an independent free
existence and here
so we've got free otherness already
talked about
free existence you know freya esta sen
but here he talks about zeb standing is
independent free existence so now this
is uh
deepening we're gonna have to come back
to this in a moment
conversely says because it lacks
perfection in itself because it hasn't
been brought to
its end it is a what is it
the picture thinking the way in which
religion is being pictured
it is a specific shape and i
notice i put here you know shape shapes
we're talking about
plural modalities plural ways which does
not attain
to what it ought to show forth that is
spirit that is conscious of itself it
shows forth something else
right it could show that forth if you're
reading that in there
but there's no necessary doing that
and so these uh gestalten
these specific shapes that religion
takes on throughout history and across
cultures
they may or may not convey
spirits actually
cognizing making sense of engaging with
itself through the things that people
tend to associate with religion belief
rituals worldviews experiences
all of those things all of those for
hegel have the potential
to be ways in which spirit grasps itself
as something more than just this
individual experience or even this
particular
religious comportment so he goes on and
he says
it it doesn't attain what it would
should show forth right
if it's shape so if religion shape is to
express spirit itself
it must be nothing other than spirit and
spirit must appear to itself or be in
actuality vase and league right uh what
it is in its essence vasen
ah sorry virtually kite right uh and
invasion so this this
duality that we've seen a little bit
earlier only by so doing
would that also be obtained which may
seem to be the demand for the opposite
so we'll come back to that a second why
a demand for its opposite the form of
free
actuality we get the third free here
right
but only spirit that is object to itself
as absolute spirit
is conscious of itself as a free
actuality to the extent
that it is in remains consciousness the
conscious of itself they're in
so when we're engaging in
religion in a certain way there's the
potential
for not just engaging but
but being absolute spirit
how that's going to play out okay well
that's what we're discussing
in this religion section and so coming
back to this
um what may seem to be the demand for
the opposite
a free actuality why is that an opposite
and why why is hagel been talking about
free over and over and over here
well you know spirit and its development
is as he's remarked
elsewhere the development of freedom
freedom grasping itself and freedom is
not a simple
concept there's no one-size-fits-all
definition of
freedom freedom is actually attained and
learned in the process of using
freedom so freedom kind of you know
unpacks itself
so kind of existentialist here isn't it
but it it you know it fits into this
and religion is a
you know overarching way
an overarching human activity a modality
of being human
that allows this to happen and it
doesn't just have the potential for it
it's got a for hegel kind of an internal
drive towards it which is often not
realized
as we reduce religion to just one you
know one thing among many in the
existence of spirit in human existence
right
this free otherness on design uh
independent free existence design free
actuality vehicle
kite being other
existing being actual being real
you put these together and you have
something like a
composite picture of the divine
attributes as a free being
right and so hegel's talking about god
here
and our relation to god and how god
comes to be realized through a
you know spirit reconciling fulfillment
of religion now has that happened at
this point no but he's he's charting out
for you
where he's going and what we're going to
hopefully get to
at the end of this spirit portion of the
work
religion portion of the work rather
fulfilling what the spirit portion of
the work
laid in religion's lap
when self-consciousness and
consciousness proper religion and spirit
in its world or spirit's existence
are in the first instance distinguished
from each other
the latter consists in the totality of
spirit so far as the moments exhibit
themselves in separation
each on its own account but the moments
are
consciousness self-consciousness reason
and spirit spirit that is
as immediate spirit which is not yet
consciousness of spirit their totality
taken together constitutes spirit in its
mundane existence
generally spirit as such contains the
previous
structured shapes in universal
determinations
in the moments just named religion
presupposes that these have run their
full
course and is their simple totality or
absolute self the course traversed by
these moments
is moreover in relation to religion not
to be represented
as occurring in time only the totality
of spirit is in time
and the shapes which are shapes of the
totality of spirit
display themselves in a temporal
succession for only the whole has true
actuality
and therefore the form of pure freedom
in the face of an other a form which
expresses itself
as time but the moments
of the whole consciousness
self-consciousness
reason and spirit just because they are
moments
have no existence and separation from
one another
just as spirit was distinguished from
its moments so we have further in the
third place to distinguish from these
moments themselves
their individual determination we saw
that each of these
those moments was differentiated again
in its own self into a process of its
own
and assumed different shapes as in for
example consciousness self sense
certainty and perception
were distinct from each other these
ladder shapes fall apart in time and
belong to a
particular totality for spirit descends
from its universality to individuality
through determination
the determination or middle term is
consciousness
self-consciousness and so on but
individuality
is constituted by the shapes assumed by
these moments
these therefore spirit in its
individuality or
actuality and are distinguished from one
another in time though in such a way
that the latter moment retains within it
the preceding one
in paragraph 679 we see hegel
beginning a thematization not
just of religion as coming after spirit
and in terms of you know consciousness
and self-consciousness
and spirit aware of itself but
specifically
in terms of for we could call them
threads or courses or whatever you want
to call them
that are being drawn together into
one totality which you know we can call
it not we can call whatever we want
using
you know the picture language or
metaphors or representation
and those four things are
these previous sections of the work
up to this point so you know we've got
consciousness first and then we have
self-consciousness
and then we have reason the much longer
section and then we have spirit
and within each of them we have sections
and we have
shapes of consciousness all that's going
to come in
now this also touches on this paragraph
touches on a very important question are
we to understand the
phenomenology as sort of a
history of consciousness in a linear
sense
where you know consciousness first goes
through the
consciousness section and you know only
after it gets to the inverted world does
it jump to
self-consciousness which seems to be at
like the beginning of
human history or at least the ancient
age right
you know and the answer is no no there's
a much more complex relationship
between consciousness spirits
consciousness in
individuals and within societies and its
relation to time and history and we're
getting a glimpse of it
here so hegel starts out saying
when self-consciousness and
consciousness proper
there's an identification here religion
right self-consciousness
proper and spirit in its world or
spirit's existence
consciousness are in the first instance
distinguished from each other so he's
going to talk about several distinctions
here
that's the first distinction the latter
so that what's the latter
spirit in its world or spirit's
existence
it's design it consists in the totality
of spirit and here he uses this term
totally
several different times in the course of
this discussion
so far as its moments exhibit themselves
in separation
each on its own account so what are its
moments we're talking really big picture
here the
the moments are consciousness
self-consciousness
reason and spirit right these
four sections that we've we've discussed
so far
each leading into the other and
oftentimes referring back to each other
so you know we see spirit
taking up things from consciousness or
self-consciousness or
reason and reworking them so he says
these moments are
and we've named them off already here
now the spirit
thing he clarifies we're not talking
about spirit
as it is fed into religion
spirit aware of itself at qua spirit
as spirit right we do have spirit that
is aware of itself
you know conscience was was being aware
of itself but it's not fully grasping
itself yet
as spirit as geist for hegel it's only
partially done so
so he says their totality the totality
of these four
you know main strains constitutes spirit
now does it constitute spirit totally
we have two polarities here right
constitutes spirit
in its mundane existence
so we've got dazzling here twice right
the existence of spirit how spirit is
how it you know goes out goes out into
what
into the world mundane existence it
takes a world for granted
it lives within a world that generates a
world for itself
all of that is happening in these four
sections of the phenomenology and you
might say well how the hell did that
happen i mean i get it for maybe spirit
and perhaps even for reason where we had
observing reason first and it's like
looking at the things of the world and
then it you know looks at
reason itself but how how does it happen
for consciousness well think back to
sense certainty and the movement to
perception
and the movement to force in the
understanding it was it was
not just grasping a world that's out
there or
moving around in a world it was
constituting a world it was
taking an active part in it right
especially with self-consciousness we
get the
social and interrelational world right
so hegel goes on and he says um
spirit as such contains the previous
structured shapes in universal
determinations
in the moments just named so structured
shapes you know
we're talking about gestalt and uni in
universal determinations
things that we've been following along
with you know who is
the master in the master slave dialectic
who is the observing reason
we could identify specific individuals
but we're really talking about like
types
aren't we and so these are shapes of
consciousness
he goes on and he says the course
traversed by these moments
is moreover uh here we go a little bit
before this religion presupposes these
have run their full course
and is their simple totality or absolute
self so
this tells us what religion not as
religious ritual as such but religion as
understood in the phenomenology
in this portion of the text is supposed
to be it is the
simple totality so we've got another
kind of totality here right
and absolute self of
all of these things and it presupposes
that they have run
their course now what does that mean he
specifies
this does not mean that they have run
their course
by occurring in time so this is not
saying ah first we have consciousness
and then we have self-consciousness and
you know we have a nice history that we
lay out and around you know 548 bc
in the west this happens and blah blah
it's not that kind of thing
right that's not how religion is working
and all of these are kind of like
proceeding along
together and mixing in with each other
what hegel's been doing up to this point
is revealed as in some sense
we could say it's a it's a simplified
falsified picture
of the development of human
consciousness yeah you know hegel
doesn't just write one book
the phenomenology of spirit right uh
it's not the only place even talks about
historical development
or any of these the subjects that he's
discussed
in the course of these these
developments but religion
in this work and religion as an
actuality for
spirit of spirit understanding itself in
a new way
is what happens when these have run
their full course and they can be drawn
into it
so he says the course traversed by these
moments is not to be represented as
occurring in time
only the totality of spirit is in time
now which totality of spirit we've got
religion is a totality of spirit we've
got
spirit's worldly existence as a totality
of spirit
well the one that encompasses them both
so
absolute spirit right not just one or
the other
so he goes on and he says only the
totality of spirit
is in time and the shapes all right
gestalten which are shapes
of the totality of spirit display
themselves in a temporal succession
right so if you know first you have
faith and then you have the
enlightenment
first you have uh this developing then
you have this developing right
now i don't know
do you really want to buy completely
into that
or just you know say okay hegel i'll go
along with you on that either one is
possible you don't you don't have to try
to
fit all of these into a perfect history
within your head
of you know world history or the
development across
cultures or anything like that even
though hegel himself was
pretty committed to a project like that
so he goes on and he says
only the whole has true actuality you
know true vehicle kite in the form of
pure
freedom in the face of another we see
this back
going back to the previous paragraph the
freedom the free
actuality the free existence
the free other other being right on
design
and um the these these
uh form which expresses itself as
time right so in time as
time two different things going on there
that we want to be attentive to
now coming back to this the real meat of
it
the moments of the whole consciousness
self-consciousness reason spirit
just because there are moments notice
what he says this
next have no existence in separation
from one another
that's important you don't first have
consciousness
going on doing its thing totally
separate from all the rest of these that
we sketched out
you don't have self-consciousness
doing its thing as a foundation or basis
for everything that comes after it
without these already being involved in
it
right so hegel doesn't begin at the
master slave dialectic
hegel doesn't begin at sense perception
hegel begins
in this work with all of these
going all of these having been all of
these
in the mind of the phenomenologist
who is presenting these things for us in
a sort of sequence and order that's
broken down into chapters or sections
but in
in reality all of these have been
happening right
so the ania kennen the recognition
that assumes such a major role in
self-consciousness
you could say is already implicitly
there in consciousness and is already
being worked out in more developed forms
in spirit and reason good to keep in
mind
and in religion so
he goes on and he says
just as spirit was distinguished from
its moments these are its moments so
we have further in the third place to
distinguish from these moments
themselves their individual
determination
we saw that each of these moments was
differentiated again
in its own self into a process of its
own and assumed different
shapes so for example in consciousness
self certainty and perception were
distinct from each other which is why
hegel
treated them in different sections those
are gestalton
and they also contain we could call them
subgestaltene right
uh you know even more particular shapes
of consciousness
that are in relation to each other
sometimes conflicting sometimes
developing past each other sometimes you
know sublating
into something else or sublating each
other so he says uh each of these
moments
right uh is is differentiated again and
these
these latter shapes fall apart in time
and belong to now here he says something
really interesting a
particular totality how can you have a
particular totality
well again this is part of hegel's
insights and his overall understanding
of things
for any given shape of consciousness
it is bounded within a certain horizon
within which the things that it takes as
essential or as important as you know
uh you know vase and leak are
it's it's world it's totality
and you can look at it and say oh man
you're so confused you know there's more
to life than just
uh stoicism and skepticism or the
unhappy consciousness right or
or the master slave dialectic they can't
realize that
fully at that point though they can have
a vague presentment that what they're
doing
is in some respect partial they are
caught up
within the framework that they're
they're working with a conceptual an
action
a interrelational framework right
that may have its own history that they
consult at its own
ends but they're all particular
totalities
and he goes on and he says spirit
descends from its universality
to individuality through determination
the determination or middle term is
consciousness self-conscious and so on
but individuality is
constituted by the shapes assumed by
these moments so
individuality is a
particular shape in the dynamic of
self-consciousness or
in the dynamic of spirit or in the
dynamic
of reason and an a particular individual
may straddle multiple shapes at the same
time this is why the hegelian dialectic
even if hegel is wrong about where it's
going and the history didn't end and all
that that sort of stuff that we often
you know say ah hagel you got things
wrong
as individuals these dynamics might
actually be or
dialectics might actually be helpful for
understanding the situation that we're
in
when we're trying to figure out why we
keep having the same conflicts over and
over again
right so he goes on and he says
individuality is constituted by these
shapes these therefore exhibit spirit in
its individuality or actuality they're
distinguished from one another in time
though in such a way that the latter
moment retains within it
the preceding one that that's you know
alf haebong or sublation again
and so this is telling us or at least
hinting to us
it's not really telling us that much in
this paragraph but it will in the
paragraphs to come
why religion matters because it's
bringing together
these these threads and
helping us to understand how spirit can
become aware of itself
not just as a totality but also in
individuals
you